esta vez nos dicen sean a de números
racionales y saben distinto de cero y
esto es necesario porque vamos a dividir
entre 20 por lo tanto lo pedimos
distinto de cero entonces es am / b en
un número racional o irracional
bueno pues pensemos un poco esto ambos
son números racionales tanto a como ven
eso significan que al ser racional lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
podemos ver a am como m / n como la
razón de los números enteros y pasa lo
mismo para ben b lo podemos ver como p /
q donde p y q son números enteros como
la proporción de dos números enteros y
es más déjeme escribirlo donde
en p y q todos son enteros y ojo todo
esto viene de la definición de lo que es
un número racional nos dicen que estos
dos números son racionales por lo tanto
los puedo expresar como este tipo de
razones ahora bien aquí será igual a / b
déjame ponerlo aquí am / b bueno pues
eso es lo mismo que m sobre n m sobre n
esto a su vez dividido entre b pero bp
entre com pe / q y bueno si te das
cuenta aquí tengo la división de dos
racionales entonces esto es exactamente
lo mismo que m entre n que multiplica al
recíproco de este aqu / p dividir sobre
una fracción es lo mismo que multiplicar
por su recíproco y esto va a ser lo
mismo que m por q dividido entre n
y ahora observa m porque será un número
entero porque este es el producto de dos
números enteros y n por p también será
un número entero porque es el producto
de dos números enteros
entonces acabo de demostrar que a sobre
b puede ser expresado como la razón de
dos números enteros lo que quiere decir
que entonces te acabo de mostrar que
entrevé seguro será un número racional
seguro será un número racional y está de
lujo así que qué te parece si hacemos
otro ejercicio más y para eso voy a
quitar esta pantalla y voy a traer por
acá el siguiente problema y dice sean
ahí ven números irracionales en esta
ocasión entonces es a entrever un número
racional o irracional y como siempre
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolverlo por
tu cuenta
ya lo mejor que hacer algunos ejemplos
con números irracionales
y ver si obtienes números racionales o
irracionales
bueno pues qué te parece si nos
imaginamos un caso hipotético y vamos a
resolverlo juntos vamos a imaginarnos un
mundo donde no se ama atom el valor de
dos veces la raíz de dos ok esto me
parece bien y b&b tome el valor de bueno
se me ocurre la raíz de 2 la raíz de 2
ok entonces cuánto es am / b bueno pues
esto sería lo mismo que dos veces la
raíz de 2 2 veces la raíz de 2 sobre la
raíz de 2 pero observa esto sería lo
mismo que 2 porque la raíz de 2 entre la
raíz de 2 se pueden cancelar y entonces
me quedaría solamente con dos y dos es
un número bastante racional porque lo
puedo expresar como la razón de dos
enteros cuando yo quiera por ejemplo
puedo decir que el 2 es lo mismo que 2
sobre 1 o 4 sobre 2 o qué sé yo de hecho
hay un número infinito de maneras en que
puedo expresar al 2 como una razón de
dos enteros entonces en este caso
de obtener un número nacional de dividir
a entrever cuando ibm eran dos números
irracionales en esta ocasión obtuvimos
un racional pero espera qué te parece si
ahora ponemos este siguiente caso
imagínate que am valgan la raíz de 2 y
que te valga la raíz de 7 que voy a
obtener de dividir a entre b
entre b bueno pues voy a obtener la raíz
de 2 entre la raíz de 7 estás de acuerdo
lo cual sigue siendo un número
irracional ojo no lo estoy probando pero
a lo que me refiero es que puedes pensar
esto de la siguiente manera esto es lo
mismo que la raíz de dos séptimos y si
te das cuenta adentro no tenemos algo
que sea un cuadrado perfecto entonces
vamos a terminar teniendo un número de
racional y bueno acá vamos dar un
ejemplo en donde empezamos con dos
números irracionales
y los obtuvimos un número irracional en
este caso tuvimos un ejemplo donde
llegamos a un número racional y también
tuvimos un ejemplo en donde llegamos a
un número irracional entonces puedo
decir que es ambos puede ser tanto
racional como irracional muy bien me
están gustando mucho así que vamos a
hacer otro más voy a quitar este y vamos
a poner aquí el siguiente y dice sea a
un número racional distinto de cero
entonces es a por 8 un número racional o
irracional bien pues la clave aquí es
que raíz de 8 está es un número
irracional y seguro te preguntas por qué
raíz de 8 es un número irracional porque
si 8 tiene un cuadrado perfecto adentro
de él pero ojo no es un cuadrado
perfecto en sí mismo la raíz cuadrada de
8 déjame ponerle aquí la raíz cuadrada
de 8 es exactamente lo mismo que la raíz
de 4 por 2 de 4 por 2 que es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 4 por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 que por cierto es lo mismo
que dos veces la raíz cuadrada de 2 y
esto de alguna manera nos lleva al punto
clave para resolver este problema porque
si multiplico un número racional por un
número irracional entonces obtengo un
número de racional eso es muy importante
porque si vemos la raíz de 8 está de
aquí es un número irracional es esta de
aquí y al multiplicar la por amd que es
un número racional como me dice el
problema entonces seguro va a ser un
número irracional seguro la respuesta es
un número irracional
estoy multiplicando un racional por un
irracional y me dan irracional muy bien
así que vamos a hacer otro más este
estuvo muy fácil y vamos a trabajar el
último vamos a hacer el siguiente dice
a un número irracional eso es muy
importante esta vez tenemos un número
irracional entonces es menos 24 más
un número racional o irracional y no voy
a dar una prueba formal de esto pero lo
que sí quiero darte es una idea
intuitiva de lo que está pasando y para
eso es bueno tomar algunos números así
que te invito a que pausa el vídeo e
intentes resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno imaginemos algunos valores para a
mí se me ocurre que a tomé el valor de
no se den menos pi muy bien si a vale
menos pin que por cierto es
aproximadamente menos 3.14 15-9 y todos
los demás es decir me refiero a que así
seguirá por siempre y nunca se repetirá
luego tendríamos menos 24 más a menos 24
más a lo cual es exactamente lo mismo
que menos 24
- pin pin lo cual es aproximadamente 27
puntos 14 15 9 y todos los demás porque
la expansión decimal es decir todo lo
que está después del punto decimal será
exactamente la misma que la expansión
decimal de pi y bueno al menos esto se
ve para este ejemplo que nuestra
respuesta será un número irracional
ahora qué te parece si le damos otro
valor a am se me ocurre pensar que a
tomé el valor de la raíz de dos buenos
ya toma el valor de la raíz de 2 tendría
menos 24 más la raíz de 2 y una vez más
no estoy haciendo la demostración aquí
pero parece que de una manera intuitiva
esto va a tener una expansión decimal
infinita la cual seguirá por siempre y
por siempre y no se repetirá
entonces este 24 sólo va a cambiar lo
que está a la izquierda del decimal pero
realmente no va a cambiar
no espera este es positivo entonces va a
cambiar también lo que está a la derecha
del decimal ya que este es un número
negativo pero de cualquier manera
nuestro resultado seguirá por siempre y
nunca se repetirá de hecho si fuera en
este caso menos la raíz de dos menos la
raíz de dos si fuera menos la raíz de
dos bueno en este caso a la derecha del
decimal tendrás lo mismo que tenías con
la raíz cuadrada de 2 y en la izquierda
del decimal simplemente tendrás un valor
distinto de sumar estos dos y ahora
tendrás menos 25 puntos lo que sea lo
que sea lo que sea entonces cuando sumas
un número racional a un número
irracional y lo hemos probado en otros
vídeos un racional más un irracional
siempre te dará irracional y si quieres
la demostración tenemos otros vídeos que
hablan de lo mismo en este tutorial